The story I hope to tell, by leveraging the negative space, is that as
time's gone on, what started as a small, somewhat local tournament or event,
has evolved into a global phenomena, both for the countries participating and
the home countries in terms of how much visitors they're looking to attract.
Notice in the early years when there may not have been such good transportation,
especially across the Atlantic, the participating countries were often
somewhat local to the game and where it's being held.
But as time's gone on,
we can see that more countries from across the globe are participating.
And the last point I'd want to draw your attention to before we leave,
is that in the beginning, and still somewhat recently, Europe and
South America often dominate participation in the game and dominate who hosts.
Well that concludes our map, so let's go and
try to add some additional features to make it more interactive.